[Applause]
[Music
] dear ones, I'm glad you
're here today, we're having a
cooking class today, what food should help, nutrition
kadow is nutritional advice that
is primarily aimed at people with migraines
because I have
had such good success with him through nutrition
here you can see me alive and well
but it was always like that because I had
severe migraines for many years
I worked at a bank when
I had green so often it was
really difficult that I
I had such a normal life I still had relatively
small children and then I
thought wow I'm in my late
30s how could it be? I
kept working but I
changed my diet beforehand and then I
realized  I found that the change in
diet helped me so well
against migraines that I
then did the nutritionist
training to make a fund
when i was
at guide for the first time a year ago, i immediately noticed that i had in-depth knowledge, i
'm right there, it
doesn't matter if i attended practical seminars,
such as accounting and taxes, in
may it was inspiring and i went
out and thought, i thought
again  what I learned
[music]
great i'm just happy when i
see that the people who gave me
advice that if
they implement things so that it works then it's
just better
i believe in second chances in life
because that was the case for me  I got out of a
difficult situation stronger
and can now step forward with
nice things
[music]